hello everyone and welcome to Game two
of the 2019 world Fisher random
championship finals it's Wesley Sona
with the white piece against Magnus
cross and the setup is the same so
basically the the rooks the gambit the
client is someone conveniently said in
the comment section but as the setup is
pretty much similar to classical chess
with the Queen's and rooks having
switched places and the district and
Knight are are differently placed but
other than that some of the ideas that
work in normal chess will work here so
without further ado after a tough game
in in round one that hand in ended in a
draw now let's see how they played out
the game - Wesley opens with d4 and now
we what sorry about that
that almost never happens no that never
happens I've never seen that
but luckily luckily we can just continue
it now so d4 and now b6 not d5 like like
we had a similar in the previous game so
nice to g3
by Wesley and Bishop to a six by Magnus
now it's already our weird move to face
especially since well now you can go for
a four which you kind of want as you
prepared with Knight to g3 because of
Bishop captures an f1 maybe you can play
it but you've never actually seen this
so you don't want to over calculate it
but I saw that leech has posted on
Twitter that they have they actually
have a few random or chess960 database
and this position has been reached to
two times so it is still not a new
position as of move to even though it's
official random so very exciting times
that that we are living in b3 preparing
c4 and now e 6 bye-bye Magnus with c4
now blocking this diagonal and d5 by
Magnus with III now strengthening the
c-4 square Bishop to e7 and now Knight
to c3 so nicely continuing development
Knight to g6 maybe preparing the castle
Bishop to d3 and here
Magnus just castles with castles by
Wesley and Knight to d7
Wesley trades once on b5 with C captors
on d5 now Bishop captures on d3 first
rook captures and he captures on d5 and
here Wesley was for Knight to f5 and it
makes sense if you can eliminate blacks
dark square bishop and make use of your
own for example this diagonal is free
for grabs
then it should be very nice magnus goes
the rook after ie8 he puts rook on a
semi-open efile maybe prepares bishop to
f8 if he doesn't want to trade but
Wesley doesn't even a lot what he plays
in Knight captures on e7 rook captures
and then out B for expanding further on
the Queen side preparing a four we have
Knight to f6 and now b5 stifling White's
development on the Queen side so Magnus
has to do something c6 is played and now
a4 we have h5 by Magnus and now h3 so
both players create some breathing space
for the king and queen to c8 Magnus now
looks for ways to bring the Queen
interval game controlling some squares
on the Kings side but also with ideas of
maybe just well not capturing at the
moment but if if something opens up on
the C file it does help to have your
queen on this file also rook to c7 could
be an idea
so B captures and c6 by way by Wesley
and now rook the e6 by Magnus he will
transfer this rook over to the C file we
have f3 taking away is some very nice
words from across ins Knights and also
preparing efore we have rook actress on
c6 and now p4 as planned we have D
captors on e 4f captors on e4 and now
Wesley has a really strong center here
if he is able to consolidate put rooks
behind it those two pawns I get the
Queen into the game develop the pieces
he should be he should be excellent here
if he just
if he can just start pushing the past
deep on for example but Magnus doesn't
tell Howard he goes Knight to e5 and of
course you cannot trade because the
rookin d3 is undefended so look back the
e3 by Wesley and now Knight the c-4 by
Magnus going after the rook on e3 we
have rook back to f3
now this Knight cannot move e5 is a
threat after the knight moves rook
captures and f7 will be an idea but here
Magnus decides to clear the board of the
two central pawns and
a la Wesleyan incredible attack so we
have rooked captures on d4 Knight to d5
by Wesley now threatening threatening
everything threatening to capture the
rook on D for threatening Knight East 7
check the fork the king and the Queen if
the if the knight captures the rook
captors and f7 is an idea it's just
crazy stuff so here
Magnus plays rook captures on e4 it gets
the rock out of harm's way and also
guards East 7 so you don't have Knight
to e7 but now Wesley has a lot of things
going for him there's a quadruple attack
on the f6 square so first let's see what
happens if you trade let's say if Knight
captures a with check rook captures you
could go rook captures G captors and now
let's say Queen captures seems like a
very nice attack but Magnus is in time
to defend with Queen to East 6 offering
the Queen trade guarding the f7 pawn so
here let's say Queen g5 check Queen g6
check and the black defense everything
ends at the variation being up upon so
not something Wesley's interested in
doing capturing with the rook runs into
pretty much the same stuff rook captures
now you can play knife captures with
chick captures captures and you go into
the same line so here Wesley played the
the most awesome move he played Bishop
to h6 which offers a lot of a lot of
thinking space for Magnus because he has
to be careful for example one nice
example is if you move the knight you're
getting check mated Queen captures and
g7 is mate on the other hand if you just
capture the bishop then you no longer
Guardi if 6 square so now is just Knight
captures on f6 check and well you just
lose material here either gonna lose
this rook or you have to give up this
rook and then there's just triple attack
against the f7 pawn you would be
completely losing here so after this
Bishop to h6 move Magnus plays in knight
yet he gets the night away although
there is no Queen g7 mate as the knight
here covers the g7 Square and here
Wesley Wesley could capture on f7 this
is what Magnus was hoping for so he
could snap the bishop on h6 and here
you're just you know you've lost the
bishop and you don't have an attack you
don't have any any good moves if rook f8
check you just move the King it's not a
problem
so after this night eh Wesley played
Bishop captures on g7 he immediately
played this and it's 18 moves for Wesley
and 21 minutes on the clock for Magnus
so what do you do here here Magnus
played the very calm night to b2 and
it's just crazy everything is you know
hanging rook after Sun f7 is hanging
rook is coming to g3 this could happen
and Magnus just calmly plays Knight to
d2 which wins the material as both of
the rooks are under attack and it
immediately goes against the rook g3
idea because if rook g3 threatening some
nice discoveries just Knight captures on
f1 and now you know all of Carlson's
pieces are on light squares and you
don't have a good discovery here because
well the match will just capture the
rook if you try a discovery Bishop h6
Turk Knight captures and you don't even
have a nice mate because the knight
still covers the g7 square so here after
Knight - D - Wesley played rook captures
on f7 he sacrificed the exchange with
Knight captures on f1 and now rook the
f8 check with King - h7 and now
Wesley retreats with the Bishop Bishop
to e5 and here someone also posted this
in the comments Wesley's heart rate was
a hundred and fifty-nine so he was
really in the moment and Carson has to
decide does he have time for Luke to c1
and can heal our rook to HEA to check
what happens after update rate check is
he getting mated or or what is happening
here so here cross and took some 10
minutes they decide what to play and in
the end he played rook to c1 he attacked
Wesley's Queen and also is threatening
some nasty discoveries of his own so
Wesley very quickly replied with rook
tha check it is the main line and it is
the best line for white so here we have
kink to g6 by Magnus and now Knight to
e7 check for king the king and the Queen
we reach the position from the thumbnail
and what can Magnus do now well he can
go King to f7 or King to g5 if King g5
it would go very bad for him
rook g8 check you have to move king h4
and now brush up to f6 check you don't
have any more moves you have to capture
the bishop and now Queen captures and f6
will be made the King has nowhere to go
the rook on
the entire G file and you cannot block
check
so after 97 check Magnus goes for King
to f7 and now again what can Wesley do
wesley could trade down everything for
example if he trades down tonight
captures rook captures with character
Sunday 1 captures an a4 now attacking
the bishop here so if King captures
Knight rook captures Bishop but now
White has rook h7 check King g6 and now
rook captures an a7 defending the bishop
from a 7 now we could trade here
characters characters and after the
knight moves we reach this position
where it's pretty equal two points each
two knights against a bishop and the
knight but should be a draw so this is
one option for Wesley Knight captures
but Wesley continues the attack with
rook to h7 check also by doing this he
defends his knight as the King was ready
to just capture it
we have Quinta Eastside by Magnus King
f8 is also fine King the e6 and now
Wesley doesn't have a way of continuing
the attack although it seems like he
should have so many pieces on the board
and across since King stolen e6 there
actually isn't a good way to continue
the attack there just isn't if Queen a
to check you can just block it Queen to
see for the rook covers this song not
nothing going on there so he goes for
the trade Knight captures on c8 we have
looked out for Sonic 1 by Magnus Bishop
captures on a1 and now Knight back to g3
and here rook captures an a7 he captures
yet another pawn and Wesley is now up
upon so what what what's going on here
Mac we have Knight to f5 Magnus goes
back with the night you don't win a
piece by rook e1 check because well just
can give to attack the knight so it's
basically a trade so first Magnus moves
it now threatens rook e1 but Wesley and
just moves the bishop bishop all the way
to age 8 it looks like a funny square to
put your bishop but you know if it works
it works nicely a slices the board in
half it's a very powerful piece and for
the moment black has no way of attacking
it so it's just a good piece and next
move Wesley is ready to pick up the d6
pawn as well so here Magnus has to
decide what to do probably rooks e4 or
rook to e1 check Fallbrook the c1
attacking the knight here he has
the character of this pawn here but
Magnus decided to play actively and he
played rook to eat you probably what
ideas of just maybe Knight nice to age
for picking off the the g2 pointer for
creating some threats but the rook to e2
is a serious blunder so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the best
move for Wesley in this position while I
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding such a nice
winning idea and for those who just want
to enjoy the show
the knight controls the e7 square which
is which is what's preventing rook to e7
so basically what who Wesley did here is
he just decided to dislodge the night
from f5 which defends the e7 Square and
he played g4 so congratulations to
everyone who found that seems like an
odd move for Magnus name is but Wesley
really made him calculate a lot he he
tired him down and here even even the
great Magnus is able to make a mistake
like this so H captures on g4 h captures
and now you have to either lose the
knight or move the knight and allow rook
to e7
Magnus moved at night to the e3 and now
Wesley just played rook to e7 check with
King to d5 and now rook dr. Sahni 8th
Wesley happily grabbed a piece and here
you don't really have any compensation
for it now it's not just that you're
down a piece or you're down a piece and
the pawn so here Carlson went for rook
to g2 check King h1 and now rook
captures on g4 offering yet another
piece well a trade basically for rook
check and picking up the bishop so
Wesley I decided Wesley decided whether
to pick it up right away or to go for
Knight captures and b6 first but he was
also he didn't want to overcomplicate it
he just went into a line that he he knew
that he could win so he played a knight
rook captures on e3 we have rook after
Sun h4 King g2 and rook captures on h8
attacking the knight here but now Knight
captures and b6 with check King c5 and
now rook to b3 so here we have a
position where it's a rook Knight and
pawn against rook if you if Wesley did
not have this point if it were just the
rook and the night against the rookin
king then Magnus would be able to draw
this but unless it was some really crazy
position that was winning by force but
with the
it should it should definitely be
winning so here Magnus will try
everything in his power to stop Wesley
from winning maybe he can draw maybe he
can get out through the 50 move room
maybe he can get a stalemate maybe maybe
Wesley will not play the absolute best
move so he will try everything so first
he has to decide how to get his King
over here to try and stop the past pawn
and how to get maybe the the White King
from not reaching the action so one idea
is rook h7 if you just stop the pawn
from behind but here white would have
rugby 5 check King c6 and now Knight to
d5 just putting the night behind the
pawn so for example after Luke a7 you
would have night before check and after
the King moves now you push a 5 and here
the pawn and the knight are creating a
nice wall so the black King cannot reach
it and then you just move the rook go go
behind with the rook or just calmly
start doing your King into the game
that's one way how you win it
so after rugby 3 Magnus doesn't like
rook h7 he goes rooked h4 maybe with
ideas of rook to b4 if he can trade
rooks and somehow force
well that somehow attack the knight and
the pawn simultaneously then he can draw
this game but we have a 5 here is
probably the most precise by Wesley but
he decided to go for rook to be 5 and he
gave Magnus some chances with King to c6
rook the b1 now as you want to start
pushing your pawn at some point and now
looked h5 by Magnus not allowing a5 so
here Wesley repeats Knight c4 and Magnus
repeats rook to h4 we have 9 back to b6
and Magnus happily repeats rook to h5
he's down a piece he definitely wouldn't
mind the draw Knights the c4 and Magnus
repeats rook to h4 so if Wesley repeats
one more time it's a threefold
repetition but of course Wesley doesn't
Wesley goes back Knight B 2 now the a4
point is nicely protected and now you
can finally activate your looks even if
the roots get traded now it's a winning
for white because even if the rooks are
off the board if you get even the King
gets here to attack the knight and pawn
simultaneously you just push the point
you give up the night and then the pawn
Queens so King back to b6 by Magnus
there are no good discoveries here and
Wesley starts bringing the King into the
game kingi 3 we have rook to d4 and now
King f3 kink Ted King to a5 by Magnus
and now King - III we have looked back
to d8 not allowing the King to cross the
D file but now rook to h1 and here
Wesley's heart rate was about a hundred
and sixty-one which is the highest
anyone had in the championship so far
and as you should be you're about to
take down the world champion of course
you you're excited so look the d5 not
allowing any checks along the H file and
enter now comes look the h4 here
Wesley's planning rook to d4 block
Carlson's influence of the rook on the
default and then just bringing his King
deeper into the position so look the g5
by Magnus you have to allow King the
three and not look back to c5 here
Wesley just blocks crossings rook and
now roped h5 of course he doesn't want
to trade rook c3 sorry Lucas came to see
- and now rook the h3 again not allowing
the King to enter the position but rook
c3 route back to h6 and now finally King
Tubby three we have rooked the b6
checked by Magnus and now King j3 so now
the king is safe here there are no more
tricks and now it's time to make more
progress we've looked the c6 by Magnus
here offering a whole look as if you
captured of course it's stalemate the
King has nowhere to go so Wesley not
interested in this way Wesley picked up
the rook and he went in front of the
room but he placed it on c4 of course he
will not capture it we have a rook just
goes back rook to h6 and an out looked a
c5 with check now finally kicking the
King away and making more progress King
before we have grouped the h1 by Magnus
rook c6 check King to a7 and now Knight
to c4 we have King b7 attacking the rook
rook b6 check King the a7 and now we
have looked the g6 now making room for
the King to enter the board looked to be
one check and now kink the a5 and here
it's six and a half minutes for Wesley
and five minutes for Magnus he will
still try to somehow save this game we
have looked back the h1 by Magnus rook
to g7 check
to be 8 and now kink the a6 here we have
rooked h4 by magnets attacking the
knight and the pawn but now rook to g8
check and it was in this position that
magnus carlsen resigned the game almost
72 and a brilliant victory for Wesley so
a brilliant start of the game brilliant
attack and then brilliantly trading down
into an endgame that he knew very much
how to win without wasting very much
time so really really in this game
Magnus was definitely outclassed so he
resigns because now it's it's too simple
over win once the King moves you're
gonna go Knights the b6 and now the pawn
just marches forward for example if King
36 or any other movie play doesn't
really matter what's taking these six
now you just play rook the c8 you cut
off the king next to place the King on
b7 and the point advances there's
nothing you can do here of course Magnus
could try a few more moves but from this
point on from Ruby a check it would just
be silly to even try Magnus knows this
and here he resigned so Wesley takes the
lead and a win in the classical time
format is three points so Magnus is now
down three points in the match which is
which is pretty huge so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it
we'll see what happens tomorrow two more
classical games and well a chance for
Magnus they equalized he started a
woulda loss against Fabi he was able to
equalize that will we'll see what
happens here I would also like to thank
Tony more guitar and an emerald bus for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the official
World random world official random
championship and and well you know
checking up in your wonderful
suggestions and and so on so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day